let the liberal meltdowns begin the
polls in New Hampshire are still open
for a few more hours but that's not
stopping The Usual Suspects from
thinking the worst of trump supporters
who just want a more prosperous economy
the new attack line is that they want a
dictator I think that we're naive to
think that he's tricking people into
picking him and then surprised he's
gonna act like a dictator what he's
offering is strongman leadership the end
of Politics the end of Elections that's
what he's selling and that's but they
are very eager to buy if you're that
voter who thinks that the system is
working against you that Washington has
ignored you and Wall Street has swindled
you and Hollywood is laughing at you you
want chaos you want something to sort of
shake up the whole system that was
always from 2015 on that was the Donald
Trump appeal Trump is just lying all the
time and the people that believe a liar
all the time are crazy and I can't even
understand I do not understand why 70
some million people out there accept a
lying constantly lying person I love
this and not to be outdone farle squad
leader Alexandria oazo Cortez is also
bashing Trump's supporters Donald Trump
is what you actually get when you want a
politician to embody all of like your
hopes and dreams and like caricatures of
yourself and yes Donald
Trump
affirms insecure men's idea of
masculinity yes they affirm insecure
people's idea of wealth internalize
misogyny
yeah in insecure white folks idea of
race Greg I want to start with you
because this infuriates me they actually
think that we want chaos as if we don't
know they're the ones causing the chaos
talk to me well this is again this is a
design problem of the industry you can't
get ratings if you operate on the best
intentions of other people so instead of
honestly asking why maybe 80 million
people 75 80 million people might want
some something that you don't want they
will call them dumb racist misogynistic
deplorable because those people don't
see what you see I don't like Taylor
Swift but I can see why a billion people
Embrace her music and and when AOC
happily psycho analyzes groups of people
then it's an invitation to return the
favor right if she can do it she's
saying that people who support Trump are
projecting their masculine insecurity
but isn't she saying that because of her
own insecurities about her boyfriend's
masculinity right she must realize how
soft and buttery and feminine
Progressive males are and it's hard to
get horny with a snowflake so it's why
and I think this is why she is so pro-
illegal immigration she's projecting her
secret desires for young viral men who
are coming here in droves and she's
stuck with pajama boy and it's driving
her crazy all these Trump supporters men
MMA fighters drives her nuts and then I
want to just say one last comment about
Chris Matthews he's been around a long
time so he has no excuse for having such
a Monumental blind spot but surely if he
was not on set and you sat him down and
contemplated the nature of Trump's Pro
popularity he would get it but if he got
it then he would never be invited back
to those shows anybody can explain
Trump's popularity right he values what
most Americans value which is success
meritocracy putting America first and
then helping others right he's also an
outsider and he pisses off the right
people this I did that in 10 seconds if
you said that to Chris Matthews he'd go
oh I get it but the moment he gets it he
will be thrown out of the system okay
all right Jesse you know they say that
we want Fascism and we want democracy to
end I mean isn't that kind of uh
counterintuitive and doesn't it kind of
indicate what they've done for the last
few years I'm sure does does it's kind
of a corporate media scop to make us not
talk about the issues instead of talking
about the issues they create a stigma
around the issue so you don't go
anywhere near the issue remember
Obamacare if you didn't like it you were
racist right want a secure border you're
a bigot if you don't want women playing
sports with guys and vice versa you're a
transphobic so no one wants to be an a
cult no one wants to vote for a dictator
be called a bad person and so it just
scares people away from actually
debating the issues and it kind of works
people come up to me just today say
Jesse I can't they whisper I'm a big fan
I like Trump but in my office work for
the medical industry I can't say ITC
this is what's going on in this country
now and for AOC I know a little
something about insecure men an insecure
man avoid voids confrontation and he
just like lets his enemies build up
their power an insecure man doesn't set
boundaries and lets those boundaries be
broken an insecure man is afraid to say
no even to people who he loves and then
watches those people descend into chaos
we are being led by insecure men and
that's why we have people who are
hyphenating their last names and so if
the country would just get back to
normal manhood where people were not
afraid
of offending everybody and just did the
right thing because it was the right
thing to do would' be in great shape
okay Harold I was at an event last night
and I was having a very heated
conversation with a Democrat who told me
that uh Donald Trump is never going to
leave office he wants to be a dictator
Forever This is a smart guy and I said
to him well then why did he leave last
time you know when he said well well
because he had to I mean what is wrong
with
people I can't speak for uh for for that
guy but I'll tell you this I've never
found it um when I was in political
office and even outside of I don't know
how it's uh uh valuable to be critical
of other people's voters uh you can be
critical of the the candidate and
perhaps say the candidate is is fooling
them and that voters should listen more
closely to them but I don't think it's
useful uh to be critical of of Voters uh
in any democrat or republican two uh
Errol Lewis who we put in who was in the
the I think he was saying little
something different at least I heard him
saying something different he was saying
in
2016 people voted for Trump because they
wanted their their lives were chaotic
and they didn't mind someone coming in
to shake it up and president Trump did
that I think the question now for voters
is we are now eight years later from
when he was elected in 2016 is that
still what voters want uh I would
encourage the Biden team I think two
things have to happen for an incumbent
to win first and foremost the economy
has to be performing and cons and people
have to feel like their lives are better
and that the econom IC plight and their
life is better if they're if they don't
feel it's better even if the numbers
suggest it is you can't tell someone
you're safe you're happy you're healthy
and you're financially secure if they
don't fill those things so the
president's got to hope that some of
those things happen in his favor now if
I were in the white house if I were at
campaign team I would run ads roll out a
line of ads and talk about the and just
use the words that President Trump has
used he said he was proud to overturn
Roy Wade he said that he would pardon
the j6 those convicted on January 6
these are things he said I'm not these
are not things made up and just let
people understand and then I would play
back things uh that that George HW Bush
played in the in the campaign against um
uh uh Mike D caucus when Mike D caucus
said things campaigns do it all the time
I would make clear uh that this is what
president Trump has said and what he
wants to do uh and if he does maybe we
should ask him these things but
criticizing voters I think is a terrible
terrible thing to do it's it's an
unamerican thing to do okay Dana wrap it
up for us so I think if think back to
last week what was the most important
thing said in this election so far it
wasn't by a politician it was by Jamie
Diamond the head of JP Morgan who was a
center left Democrat who took the
opportunity in Davos to tell the left
wow what you're doing is wrong why are
why can't you be at least openminded to
what these people who would vote for
republicans and Trump what they are
thinking what they're wanting he was
trying to ask them to be a little bit
humble and a little bit gracious and so
show a little bit of mercy and also to
maybe look in the mirror and realize
that one of the reasons they're so
worried is because they think they're
going to lose again it's another reason
why I don't think Michelle Obama would
get in the race one I don't think she's
ever going to I don't think she likes
politics and read the cind Cindy Adams
says do you think she wants to risk
losing to president Trump no way the
other thing is what Rachel matow said
that Trump wants the end of Elections
well tonight you're going to see results
in a wrin campaign for the Democrats and
Biden where the DNC has already said
that nobody's vote here is going to
count as the judge said in the a block
so who's who's doing the election
interference like I this is what I'm
asking for a little Grace a little bit
more Mercy for everybody and to humbly
listen to people who you might not agree
with and the last thing I'd point out
this is going to be the longest general
election campaign in history if they use
all this hyperbole now I don't know what
they're going to say by next week very
good point Sena everyone I'm Brian kilme
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now